parça em inglês é bolsa agora Puff é
periquito veja bem perse bolsa periquito
quer dizer na pronúncia por causa de um
R você pode estar pedindo ou uma bolsa
um periquito não não tem como aprender
uma língua que a gente bota uma sinuca
de bico dessa o cara pensar vou comprar
uma bolsa Aí você tem que analisar muito
bem a situações porque veja bem o
cenário porque se tu tá no Cabaré se tu
vai pedir um brinquedo e acidentalmente
erra pronúncia e pede uma bolsa OK agora
se tu tá numa loja de bolsa você tá
pedindo para uma mulher e acidentalmente
tu pede um periquito amigo da
circunstâncias atuais de repente eu sou
até preso perigoso mano um dia desse eu
tava nos Estados Unidos mamãe ligou para
mim um estragou uma bolsa para mim meu
levo não ele Peça qualquer coisa uma
mesa table bem facinho de falar